(GRATING AND RUMBLING)
DAENERYS TARGARYEN:
I know what my father was.
What he did.
I know the Mad King earned
his name.
-(ROARING)
-AERYS TARGARYEN:
Burn them all!
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
ROBERT BARATHEON:
I'll kill every Targaryen
I get my hands on.
CERSEI LANNISTER:
Everyone who isn't us...
is an enemy.
JOFFREY BARATHEON: Ser Ilyn,
bring me his head.
BALON GREYJOY: We are ironborn.
We take what is ours.
ROOSE BOLTON: The Lannisters
send their regards.
(CATELYN STARK SCREAMING)
OLENNA TYRELL:
You don't think I'd let you
marry that beast, do you?
HIGH SEPTON:
I now proclaim Cersei
of the House Lannister...
(WHOOSHING)
Protector of the Seven Kingdoms.
DAENERYS: Lannister, Targaryen,
Baratheon, Stark, Tyrell.
They're all just spokes
on a wheel.
This one's on top,
then that one's on top,
and on and on it spins.
(GRATING)
Crushing those on the ground.
-(RUMBLING)
-(ROCKS CLATTERING)
NED STARK: Same thing is coming
for all of us.
JON SNOW: There's only one war
that matters...
the Great War.
And it is here.